[Music]
I know there must be many thoughts going
through your mind right now is this the
right place for me do I belong here let
me assure you that we see something in
you something you may not even see
yourself even if you do have X-ray
vision congratulations and welcome to
gulin
University you know when golden BL
flames on is close been off making me a
little it's like a big fire Acy cucumber
Golden Boy Jordan Andre they're going
all the way they could save thousands of
people I was come up with your superhero
name want to hear
it bloody Marie that's terrible okay
coagula even
worse I'm not going back to the [__]
wood there's weird [__] going
on who else would be told no no body
don't say the mother word about
this what's going on it's lights there
are evil people at this school this is
way bigger than us we need to make this
right this is your shot at real
power remember no tiny action hero [__]
get it got it good sweet
Jesus digging for the truth is a rush
this is just a tiny bit [__] isn't it
don't answer that it's [__]
rhetorical it's just a matter of time
before they find out about everything
else we're doing if the wood is exposed
we all have a big potentially fatal
problem it's
like you're [__] up I'm [__]
up the one thing that is really apparent
now is that we are all [__] up it's
light
[Music]
a